[Applause]
it's a toscano anderson rebound you feel
good for him first time he's begun a
season with the firm slot
on a roster
he's had to fight and claws way to the
nba curry put release three no
curry staggers back the other way and
fell fell
there was moisture over there there's a
long shot which goes down good shot
by malik bunk with the three and someone
spilled
something on the floor curry wiping his
hands
you've got to keep the beverages at bay
was it that guy with no mask
where those people look at these
i think that happened right in front of
money mayweather floyd mayweather the
champ who's going to argue with him
curry's hey i'm sorry knock that over
curry's going to go to the bench
and i'm not sure
[Applause]
i think it's all over his shoes as well
let's watch it again here's the quick
trigger here by steph
into the lap
as he starts to head on up yep it's
slippery over there
moisture
doesn't even look like anything spilled
over there but in a cut then a cut yeah
[Applause]
we told this in the first half but
kerr was raving about the condition
he said it's not just what he showed in
camp it was his build up to where he was
when he got to camp
and steve said it was it just you know
he just admires him on so many levels
he's 33
the all-time leading warriors scorer
passing wilt last year led the league in
scoring last season
i had a chance to speak with him last
week and he's always talking about
the evolution
of his body
and becoming a better shooter in his
game and i said wait a minute you
averaged 32 points you were third in in
the mvp voting are you telling me you
have new trick he's like absolutely i'm
gonna have new tricks he's always trying
to work and better himself which is
scary for the rest of the league